Hôm chỉ là mình hương, quý viên bồi chính trị, bị thưa Trung Quốc đảng,
trưởng bán tổ chức Trung Quốc, hay mặt bán chủ tịch,
chính bây báo cáo của bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bà,
về công tăng nhân sử bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn.
Đây hồi đạt thiên hành thảo lận và biểu quyết thông qua số lượng
ở viên bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn,
là hai xem đồng trí của một trăm tám đi động trí ở viên chính thức
và hai味 động trí ở viên giữ quyết giữ quyết.
Các bạn biểu thâm sự đại hội làm việc tại loa tên kéo,
thảo lận báo cáo của tăng nhân sử bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn,
ứng cờ, đề cờ và nghiêm kiểu các tài liệu hồ sơ nhân sử.
Đóan trụ tịch nghiê đồng trí trưởng loàn báo cáo
về kích quả thảo lận của các loàn đại biểu,
đối với báo cáo của tăng nhân sử bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn.
Viet hướng cờ đề cờ, các trường hợp sinh xuất khỏi dạy sách ứng cờ,
đề cờ và dạy sách bán chức hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn.
Bán chức hình chua thích báo cáo này hội và biểu quyết thông qua dành sách bầu cờ
bán chấp hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn.
Bầu bán kìm biểu bán kìm biểu lứng dẫn việc bầu cờ.
Đại hội tiến hành gipe biểu bảo biểu công bố kết quả và thông qua dành sách
các đồng trí trúng cờ và bán chấp hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn.
Hãy mấy bà thức một lần hành hình không chấp hệ sấu,
buổi sáng, đại biểu đại hội yi.
Bán chấp hành Trung Quốc đảng Phó Mỹ Bốn tiến hành hội yi lần thuy nhất,
bù chiều, đại hội hội bán bán mạng.